the two-party systems inevitable the
framers designed a constitution that
they thought would be without political
parties they didn't like political
parties I thought political parties were
divisive I thought political parties
would ruin the Commonwealth as they saw
it they didn't like them and yet they
designed a system in which parties very
quickly arose and we're never going to
go away and the reason is simple that in
a country as large as diverse with so
many clashing interests as the United
States it's going to be necessary for
those you know those it's going to
become necessary to find a focus to find
a focus for your you know political
political actions parties have become
that focus they very quickly became that
focus now the question is why don't we
have a multi-party system one it warn't
we more like Italy say or even France or
the European parliamentary system well
that's the answer is that we're not a
parliamentary system because we have the
system that we do and because it's based
on the idea of first-past-the-post in
other words the person who gets the most
amount of votes will win the election
nothing that proportional representation
if you get 10 percent of the votes
you're not going to get 10 percent of
the power you're gonna get nothing on
that account then the pressure is very
very strong for there to be eventually a
two-party system third parties can come
in but and they can have a tremendous
amount of influence in shaping you know
the major parties but as the greatest
orient once said third parties are like
bees they sting and then they die so
they make their sting but because no a
third party will always almost
inevitably help the party they are most
unlike as you saw with say the Nader
campaign in 2000 who got elected they
have their effect but then they very
quickly disappear so I think the two
parties it's not so much that I have
some metaphysical or ontological love
for two parties as a thing it's rather
that's the way the Americans
constitutional system works now if you
change the constitutional system of
course that will change as well but it's
embedded in the way
was set up in 1787 88 and it continues
that way to this day